GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LEAKED EMAILS MADE IT CLEAR THAT
THE 2016 DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY WAS
RIGGED AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS
AND IN FAVOR OF HILLARY CLINTON.
NOW IT'S LOOKING LIKE THE 2020
RACE MIGHT HAVE SIMILAR
PROBLEMS.
TULSI GABBARD HAS LOGGED AT
LEAST 2% IN SEVERAL DOZEN POLES
BUT THE DNC DOES NOT WANT HER ON
THE DEBATE STAGE AND THEY ARE
CLAIMING NOW THAT THOSE POLES
ARE NOT CERTIFIED POLES SO
GARBER LIKELY WON'T MAKE THE
NEXT ROUND OF THE PRIMARY
DEBATES.
MICHAEL TRACY HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
GRITTY JOINTS TONIGHT.
SO, I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MANY OF OUR VIEWERS ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR TULSI GABBARD, PROBABLY
NONE.
BUT WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
TULSI GABBARD IS A VALUABLE
VOICE AND WE SHOULD HEAR FROM
TULSI GABBARD.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME, I DO WANT TO
BE PARANOID, BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY DON'T
WANT HER VOICE INCLUDED.
AM I BEING A CONSPIRACY PERSON?
>> YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISE, SHE
DOES TEND TO GENERATE ACTUALLY A
SOMEWHAT SIGNIFICANT AMONG EVEN
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERTARIANS
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS A FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
LEFT-WING POLICY AGENDA BUT SHE
HAS SOMETHING ABOUT HER, I DON'T
KNOW, AMBIENCE THAT DRAWS AN
IDIOSYNCRATIC RANGE OF SUPPORT
FROM ACROSS THE SPECTRUM AND I
THINK THAT HAS ROBBED CERTAIN
PEOPLE THE WRONG WAY.
I'M NOT GONNA ALLEGE A
CONSPIRACY AS TO WHY SHE IS
LIKELY TO BE EXCLUDED FROM THE
NEXT DEBATE BUT I AM GOING TO
ALLEGE THAT THE CRITERIA TO THE
DNC IS USING TO DETERMINE WHO IS
INCLUDED AND WHO IS EXCLUDED IS
LAUGHABLY ARBITRARY.
AS I MENTIONED IN AN ARTICLE
THAT I WROTE THIS WEEK AND A
REAL CLEAR POLITICS, GABBARD HAS
GOTTEN OVER THE REQUIRED BULLING
THRESHOLD IN TWO SEPARATE POLES
AND TWO SEPARATE EARLY PRIMARY
STATES.
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" AS A
NEWSPAPER WITH THE WIDEST
CIRCULATION IN NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
THE POST AND COURIER IS THE
NEWSPAPER WITH THE WILDEST
CIRCULATION IN.
GABBARD HAS GOT HER PLACE AT 2%
OR MORE IN BOTH PUBLISHED BY
THOSE TWO NEWSPAPERS BUT THE DNC
AND ITS BIZARRE MYSTERIOUS
INFINITE WISDOM HAS DECREED
AGAIN ARBITRARILY THAT THOSE
POLES ARE NOT APPROVED.
THEY ARE NOT, YOU KNOW, THEY
DON'T SATISFY SOME WEIRD
CRITERIA THAT THAT NOBODY CAN
QUITE ASCERTAIN SO WHILE I'M NOT
GOING TO ALLEGE AN OVERT
CONSPIRACY ALTHOUGH IT'S TRUE
THAT EVERYBODY FROM DAWN OF A
ZERO TWO ELIZABETH WARREN ALLEGE
THAT THE PREVIOUS PRIMARY CYCLE
WAS QUOTE, RIGGED.
BUT, YOU'D BE FORGIVEN FOR
HAVING THAT IMPRESSION GIVEN HOW
OBSCURE AND SORT OF INSCRUTABLE
THE CRITERIA THAT THE DNC IS
USING THIS TIME AROUND TO IT I'M
NOT SAYING THAT SULCI SHOULD
NECESSARILY HAVE SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES OR THAT THE RULES
WEREN'T LAID OUT A MONTH AGO
WHICH THEY WERE ABOUT THE RULES
DON'T SEEM TO HOLD UP TO ANY
KIND OF LOGICAL SCRUTINY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: AND WE KNOW FOR A
FACT THEY DESPISE HER BECAUSE
SHE'S CHALLENGED THEIR